Bonjour monsieur, excusez-moi de vous déranger, est-ce que vous pourriez m'indiquer comment est-ce qu'on va à la mairie d'Orléans, s'il vous plaît ?
Oh là, c'est pas par là, vous êtes trompés là !
Oui, on attend que c'est trompé !
Oui, du tout ! Alors, vous connaissez un peu la cathedrale dernière ?
Oui !
Bah, c'est juste à côté !
C'est le plus grand des liens, c'est ça ?
Voilà, exactement, c'est juste à côté, après vous...
À droite, à gauche ?
À gauche !
À gauche ?
À gauche, et vous y verrez des petites marches !
D'accord !
Celle-là, la mairie !
Celle-là, la mairie, d'accord !
Est-ce que je peux vous dire encore des petites mythes ?
En fait, on est étudiante en sciences du langage à Orléans, et on fait un portrait sonore de la ville d'Orléans.
Faut répondre à 2-3 petites questions, ça prend vraiment pas beaucoup de temps.
Allez, désolé, désolé, t'façon, j'ai un peu de temps !
Parfait ! Par contre, c'est enregistré ?
Ah bah, c'est pas grave !
C'est plus... Ah mais bon, alors, vous savez, mais moi ici, tout à fait !
T'en veux ?
Alors, quel quartier habitez-vous ?
Région de Vignes !
Région de Vignes, d'accord ! Est-ce que vous aimez ce quartier, cette rue ?
Pourri !
Pourri ? Pourquoi ?
Parce qu'ils disent que c'est un privé, mais bon, c'est une porcherie, quoi !
Les gens, ils te jettent tout par la fenêtre, on va passer les détails, mais bon, bref !
D'accord !
Si vous deviez parler d'Orléans à des amis qui ne connaissent pas la ville, vous la décriverez aux connards ?
Bien, mais bon...
Bien, mais ça dépend lequel quartier, ça dépend...
Il y a des monuments à voir, ça, c'est sûr, mais bon, après...
D'accord !
Quel est votre vieux préféré dans la ville ?
Moi, ça fait 33 ans que j'habite là, à force !
Si je peux partir de là, honnêtement, je sortirais d'ici !
Ah, mais vous n'avez pas de vieux préférés dans Orléans ?
Exactement !
Très bien !
Et enfin, si vous deviez prendre une photo d'Orléans, vous la décriverez où ?
En France, la photo d'Orléans ?
Ah, ça, c'est une question que je ne sais pas du tout !
Par exemple, qui vous plait plus qu'un autre, ou un quartier, un lieu...
Du tout !
Est-ce que je peux vous donner votre âge et votre profession, s'il vous plaît ?
23 ans, pour les agents de sécurité !
D'accord, très bien !
Enfin, je vais vous demander de me redire le trajet pour aller à la merine et enregistrer cette fois, s'il vous plaît !
D'accord, alors...
Calédrale d'Orléans, la première à gauche, parce que tu verras, il y a des escaliers...
D'accord, et c'est là !
Et pour le pire des cas, tout le monde n'est pas assorti !
D'accord, merci beaucoup !
Au revoir, merci !
Bonne journée, monsieur !
Au revoir, surtout, et puis merci !
Au revoir !